to answer your question about what i've
learned along the way is is really
mostly about myself um
and how to
to be better at working with others and
so i think it really start within you
um
and that's something i definitely didn't
know
you know 20 years ago where
um
i was mostly um
out outward facing and not really
thinking about my own challenges and how
i could uh
be better myself to actually be better
with relationship with others um
so i think that that would be probably
one of my biggest learning is you know
start uh
reflecting on yourself and then you'll
be better at working with others
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lumitech
sponsored by homeward ventures hippo
insurance oppos labs synergy global
hillel at stanford leap birthright excel
serona partners and in media partnership
with ctec
welcome to 20 minute leaders and today
we're talking about sports and sports
mentality welcome miriam gles founder
and ceo of athletes soul
miriam is the founder of athlete seoul a
non-profit organization which supports
athletes as they transition away from
sports and the co-founder of the women's
sports forum which promotes the
well-being of female athletes glass is a
former olympic synchronized swimmer she
competed for france at the 2000 olympics
and for australia at the 2008 olympics
she has worked in marketing and
sponsorship for echo hotels in france
thailand australia and french polynesia
she was a high performance consultant
and coach for bridge swimming before
london 2012. she became the high
performance director and then ceo of usa
synchronized swimming after moving to
the us in 2012. glaze is passionate
about sports and wellness she lives in
venice california with her husband and
11 year old daughter
all right let's do this miriam glass
thank you so much for joining me on 20
minute leaders i'm so honored and
privileged to have you here how are you
i'm doing great thank you thanks for
having me on the uh on the interview
of course of course i'm we're gonna have
a great time because i love talking
about leadership from a personal
perspective and from experiential
perspective
i can't think of more inspirational
leaders
than than people who are in sports and
not only who are in sports but dedicated
their lives to both be incredible
athletes but then doing really doing
really good for the world and and i
think that really you know is the
embodiment of sort of your career having
participated in four olympics if but in
in in positions for four different
countries from the french national team
australian national team a great britain
and and united states and
then taking on the role of the ceo of
the usa artistic swimming with in
between working for a big hotel in
marketing and business development only
now to be the founder and ceo of
athlete's soul sort of closing the loop
and so in incredible incredible
experiences and i i want to distill with
you you know what you've learned from
these experiences as a leader yourself
leading others and things that you're
going to take with you for many many
years so miriam thank you so much for
joining me today
well thanks for this introduction and uh
i have to
give you a big disclaimer as we start is
that um i feel that all of it happened
by accident
um you know just opportunities that i
that i i grabbed as they came along to
be honest
um
but yeah
to answer your question about what i've
learned along the way is is really
mostly about myself um
and how to
to be better at working with others and
so i think it really start within you
um
and
that's something i definitely didn't
know
you know 20 years ago where
um
i was mostly um
out outward facing and not really
thinking about my own challenges and how
i could uh
be better myself to actually be better
with relationship with others um
so i think that that would be probably
one of my biggest learning is you know
start uh
reflecting on yourself and then you'll
be better at working with others
take me back to the moment you're six
and you're watching synchronized
swimming
in front of the television
what was that was that the moment of
decision did you know already that this
is your path this is what you're going
to work tirelessly for for many many
years
you know i had one of these uh
aha moment i guess
where i watched that sport on tv and
i looked at my mom and i said well this
is what i want to do i think there was
really an attraction
to the sport and
i had found
you know in that moment had found
something that
seems to be what i wanted to do
and it's hard to like
kind of really realize how can you know
at six years old um
but i tried out and
i don't think i remember at least in the
in the first you know five to seven
years i don't remember one day not
morning not
wanting to go to training and practice
and um
and be disappointed by it so there was
definitely an attraction and i think
really really early on um
i mentioned that i wanted to go to the
olympics and um i had that clear goal
pretty pretty early on um probably as
early as 10 years old but why miriam
what was it that made you every day want
to get out of bed i'm sure in crazy
hours to go and and do synchronized
swimming was it you know the sport
itself was it the swimming the teamwork
what what what was it
um
i'm not quite sure to be honest what um
started it it was
really um i definitely had a passion for
the water so being
being at the pool being in in my element
that felt really comfortable
um even though i think i was cold all
the time
um
i like the challenge i think i was uh
inspired by the other uh
older athlete in the club that i was
training at and i always wanted to i had
to drive i wanted to be better than them
i wanted to
uh try what they were doing i remember
pretty early on like i would be training
in one of the lane and then the older
and more experienced athlete would be
training on the other side and all i
wanted to do was not what i was given
but what they were doing and so i would
like to stay afterwards and practice to
uh try to do what they were doing um and
then showing the coach you know okay i
can do this can you move me to the other
group uh so i'm not quite sure i i was
uh really passionate about it and listen
i had played tennis before it was not my
thing definitely um
i don't i think i was more of a
distraction in the class but this was
something i could focus on for a long
period of time and i would never get
bored of
amazing
i i love it now if you i i can't let
this you know interview go by without
having to ask for at least one story
from the olympics i don't get to talk to
many olympians
tell me you know what what is that like
what is it like going to not one olympic
but four olympics and with four
different countries
so i think uh the first of the picks a
is really the one that you remember the
most
um
because everything becomes
a surprise everything is
amazing
grandiose and especially for someone who
comes from a small sport a niche sport
where there's not that many spectators
going to your first olympics he's
you know walking in the stadium and
having all
uh thousands and thousands of people
watch you same thing at the pool
um this would be the moment that you
definitely remember um is is having all
these people look at you and and come to
treyon cheer you on
um and then
you know
aside from that
my memories are really the journey that
comes before and the hard work that was
put in it and you can't really
um
cut that off from the final experience
it's sort of like packaged together
especially for the first olympics in
sydney like it was two years of really
hard work training with the team
together
with experiences that build for that
moment so it's sort of all packaged
together
same thing with competing in beijing
with the australian team there were a
few years before that leading up to that
moment especially in a sport where you
create a choreography
that you will practice for a couple of
years and then compete in
in the olympics afterwards so you really
have that momentum of
building a project
working at it and finally presenting
your project
um and then competing for two different
countries was really amazing um
they have complete different approach to
the olympic spirit um
it you know there's a different culture
with it and then participating in in
other
olympics in a different role was also
extremely exciting although i was less
in control
and that can be a little bit frustrating
where you feel that you're
you're there you're there to support uh
but at the end of the day you're not
performing and so you don't have that
part of control where when i was an
athlete
although i had the the stress and
and the pressure i was in control of
that stress and pressure by being able
to uh control my performance so
yeah that for my four
last question about the olympics and
then
and then i and then i want to transition
to athlete soul because i think what
you're doing is so interesting
miriam take me to the moment
right before your first synchronized
swim in your first olympics
you're standing there what goes through
your mind i'll never get to experience
the moment like this in my life
what
help me get there what what do you what
do you experience at that moment
so actually so this is back to sydney um
so that was my first olympics and
i think we had worked so hard and we
were so ready we could have not done
more than what we had done
and
there was not very much that was going
through my mind before we competed
because i felt
we were ready
and
unlike also competition where i felt
okay i need to be sure to do this there
or i need to be sure to do this so i
don't know if this is gonna work
this time i
i felt pretty peaceful actually i
thought that
um we had done it we had done everything
we could and so
that was a really
exciting moment
to be able to experience that at one of
your top competition is walk on the deck
and be like okay
i've got this
um so that's how i felt in sydney even
though we had a very difficult warm-up
um i was actually on one of the
acrobatics that we were doing which was
the first where we had a myself stand on
the feet of another athlete and coming
out of the water
um this was the first time that was done
in the sport it was a very dangerous
acrobatic that never worked in warm-up
okay miriam that exact moment you've
practiced for 15 times you've never got
to work dangerous acrobatic
and you're you're living with a
cliffhanger here
that's exactly right and um
none of the none of my teammate or
coaches wanted to
kind of look at me i think before we we
went for that swim because everybody was
scared and for some reason i wasn't
scared i felt like
i don't have a choice this has to work
this is the moment you've been working
on for all these years and whatever
happened this will this you this will
work and you'll make it work and so
you've got to convince yourself this
this is going to happen it will happen
well because you don't want to make an
embarrassment of yourself at the
olympics
um
so in some unbelievable for some reason
i found i found my piece before
going you know and
uh
yeah
it worked in the actual
scenario right in the actual competition
it worked
it worked in the competition no problem
we had a good swim we performed
okay the way we want so it was all good
okay okay i just needed to make sure to
wrap the story because i got a little
concerned towards the end but we're all
good so miriam transition with me to
your work post being an athlete so both
as a coach as a ceo as a business
development as marketing and
specifically today with athlete seoul
where does the inspiration for that come
from
so um the inspiration for athletes all
kind of comes from multiple directions
part of it is from my personal
experience with athletic athletic
retirement i actually um
was asked by my coaches to choose
between sport and academics
after the sydney olympics going into the
athena olympics so i ended up going to
business school and leaving the sport
and really leaving the sport for good um
with this idea of like diving into a
different part of my life and i was
lucky enough to be able to to come back
into the sport and compete again and
have closure in my second retirement
but i think what i learned from it was
that
i felt this was pretty backward
having to ask someone to choose between
two really highly competitive
environment and why not being able to do
both and find ways to
create a
third pass
why do you have to do this or this can
we find
another solution so i think that was
part of the inspiration
um and then the rest is also observation
from
the word of sport where my experiences
was very
not very different from other athletes
i've seen a lot of athletes who've
struggled with their transition and
retirement
whether it was because it wasn't their
choice because of injuries or they were
slowly focused on sport and had nothing
else on the side
um
so these two things were the inspiration
and then discussing and working with
other former athletes who were in that
space of athletic retirement and had to
observe observe
the same challenges i think altogether
we wanted to do something different
and something that would be available to
all athletes
from any sport any level and most of all
that would be
non-profit
in the sense that it would be accessible
financially for athletes to um to
participate and receive the support
so so what is athlete's soul
so athlete is a non-profit organization
that
was founded by former athlete and is run
by a former athlete
with the mission to support
athlete as they transition away from
sport but we also
raise awareness about the challenges of
athletic retirement
and we do this through
many different services educational
resources courses
group coaching
individual coaching
basically uh different
resources that help athletes before
during and after their transition from
sport and the goal is really to like
help athletes be better prepared for
what comes next but also develop beyond
sport
and then facilitate and even accelerate
their process of transitioning into
their next chapter
why do you think we don't hear enough
about the challenges of the transition
of athletes
from sports to their next professional
lives why is this something that we
don't hear enough about
well i i think that
you know
we want to hear
about athletes when they're at the top
of their games and when they're
doing amazing feats
um
i think with the change
a little bit the evolution and mentality
where we see more athletes now speaking
out about mental health
we are starting to get into
those topics of of more um
you know some of the difficulties that
athletes face and perhaps athletic
retirement will come more to the
forefront
but the reality is you know when when
you're done with your sport you just
become
like a normal person and
um
i think this is also why it becomes
difficult to deal with and challenging
is you you love you lose this whole
athletic identity that you have been
building for many many years
and so um
nobody is really interested in hearing
you know what you're struggling with
when your time is over
um and that's sort of where we come into
the picture is is to help those that are
struggling with this
incredible
what is it like for you to
you know take this position now work
with athletes you know sort of close the
loop with your own professional career
and your athletic career what you know
how do you experience what you're doing
now um
it's extremely rewarding
uh i get to
work with athletes all day long and for
my athlete i've actually
in the last
three years through this work i've made
some
i've met some incredible
uh people and talked about things that
were never talked about when i was an
athlete
so i feel
pretty lucky to be able to work with
such individuals but also to
kind of change the narrative on this
topic
and
yeah it's it's just incredible and and
much more
in line with what i would like to do
and it's not necessarily about you know
going to the olympics and the big
competition it's really just helping
um individuals with their their own
journey how do we make that
as best as we can
incredible miriam i want to thank you so
much
for these 20 minutes for the work that
you're doing for athletes
for the inspiration that i'm sure you've
served so many people in four different
countries and the four different
olympics that you that that you've been
a part of i think that you know i it's
inspiring for me people that go through
these really intense experiences and i
can i i know
a little bit about how
difficult it is to get to the position
that you were at and competing at the
level that you competed it competed in
and i think it's inspiring that you're
then coming and closing the loop
identifying this pain point and then
coming and solving it at scale with
athlete's soul
and i just love it and thank you for
spending this time with me and i can't
wait to share this with the world thank
you very much
thank you michael thanks for having me
sorry for the technical difficulties
um but yeah thanks for the time in the
questions
thank you very very much